ils font parfois face à des
comportements revendicatif violents ou
difficile lundi 29 mars une trentaine
d'élus se sont rendus au centre blaise
pascal pour suivre une formation de
gestion des incivilités les situations
fréquentes aujourd'hui il ya un niveau
d'exigence élevé de la part des
habitants avec un niveau de tolérance
particulièrement bas et le maire et et
dans l'antre 2 donc on vient le voir
avec une demande toujours urgente
pressante et avec une solution apporter
immédiatement
la formation a été proposée à l'ensemble
des élus des yvelines des représentants
de proximité amené à voir ce genre de
situation au quotidien
aujourd'hui on a des des élus qui
viennent de saint germain en laye où de
l'ouest du département où tout juste à
côté de de magny les hameaux on a des
collègues du mini 110 ou de voisins par
exemple qui sont là l'objectif est qu'au
fur et à mesure des prochaines dates
aussi on puisse justement couvrir
l'ensemble du territoire pour permettre
à tous les élus qu'il souhaite d'avoir
cette information objectif de la
formation donner des clés aux élus pour
éviter qu'une situation ne dégénère
apaiser le dialogue ou encore trouver
des solutions verbal on a tous un vécu
donc on a tous des bonnes idées mais
c'est dans des situations où le stress
est présent c'est vraiment avoir les
petits outils simples pour agir autant
que possible à ce situation difficile
cette première réunion s'inscrit dans un
cycle d'autres formations sur les
incivilités et la cyber sécurité devrait
avoir lieu prochainement